an award-winning musician had thousands
of dollars worth of equipment stolen
here in las vegas the performer was here
from louisiana at sam's town hotel and
gambling hall off boulder highway when
he says his trailer was taken madison
kimbrough joins us live tonight with the
story madison
musician terrence simeon was performing
in vegas the last week of february when
he had his trailer stolen you can take a
look that we're right near the area of
sam's town hotel and gambling hall it
happened within the parking lot while
the musician and his band mates were
sleeping as security footage from the
casino shows a u-haul truck towing their
trailer away in the middle of the night
unfortunately you can't see the u-haul's
license plate or the identity of the
people involved in the video from
guitars to keyboards accordions to cds
and merchandise
35-thousand dollars worth of equipment
was gone overnight a first for simeon
and his bandmates
i've been a touring musician since 1985
almost 40 years we've been on the road
exporting our music all over the world
and nothing like this has ever happened
to us
we love vegas we love the people of
vegas you know we don't blame them for
this but
we just you know this is this is was a
shock i mean you know to wake up one
morning and
all that we had to make our living with
all of our tools were gone
their band terrance simeon and the
zydeco experience had to cancel the rest
of their tour because they didn't have
enough equipment to play with terence
has filed a police report and the hope
is that their trailer will be found with
all the items still inside the simeon's
band was playing creole music from
louisiana for several schools across the
valley and also performed at the water
street plaza in henderson we have their
gofundme page up on our website attached
to this story if you want to contribute
and help them out reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now